this is a production of Cornell
University
okay all right Matt thanks for the
introduction and uh thank you all so
much for being here like seriously I'm
really excited to share this
retrospective of my PhD and I'm really
excited I can do this in person because
last time I did a talk like this it was
2020 it was the pandemic and just like
everyone in the department I was working
remotely
um and you know 2020 was a crazy time
but being someone studying Food Systems
between 2020 and now has been so
interesting right 2012 or the pandemic
in general brought so many things about
our food systems that we study directly
into our community like do you remember
this I mean it was like mid-march 2020
and I went into Aldi and it looked like
this and I was pretty shocked right and
this was the pandemic showing us that
globalized systems or globalized Food
Systems can be quite vulnerable to
things like pandemics or geopolitical
issues
all right at the same time our food
system was being constrained by natural
climate disaster you might remember that
California had some pretty big fires uh
this was their biggest fire year either
by a factor of two okay
that was 20 20. uh in addition China had
historic flooding and this affected 23
percent of their agricultural land it's
a ton of productivity all right and
while all of this was happening I think
the average consumer was realizing that
people who work in our food systems are
super essential to putting food on our
tables yet they're grossly under
appreciated okay and and you know today
we can go to the supermarket and and
um that you know the this shelves are
pretty full and uh you know pandemic is
under control but none of these issues
are resolved right let's just think
about climate change
it's kind of ironic that the same areas
in California that had historic fire
are going historic uh flooding right now
okay and on the other side of the world
in China the same places that had
flooding had the hottest summer on
record in 2022 and the rivers that
overflooded ran dry and so what this
shows us is that climate change isn't
just more extreme weather right it's
extreme variability
and that's so problematic for farming
right Farmers require the ability to be
able to predict climates and weathers
and so the Farms of the future they need
to be resilient to climate change okay
but they also should do their part in
trying to minimize environmental damage
and this is because agriculture accounts
for 40 of the world's land area that's a
ton of space and so considering how much
land area is consumed by agriculture it
should be problematic to us that you
know things like 64 of agricultural land
run the risk of pesticide pollution
we know that this pesticide pollution
can be harmful to both human health
and biodiversity okay now pesticides are
a really broad class of chemicals
they're as their name implies literally
anything that'll deal with a pest so
when we break down pesticides by their
usage glass you'll note that both
historically
as well as today the main type of
pesticide are herbicides and hopefully
this shows that a good way to make
agriculture
thus degrading to the environment would
be working towards helping Farmers be
less resilient on herbicides okay and
and working on more sustainable weed
management now another really standard
weed management practice is tillage and
just like pesticides there's nothing
inherently wrong with tillage but
Reliance on tillage can create systems
that degrade soil health and cause
erosion and this isn't like some barely
statistically significant change in soil
this can mean some pretty major losses
in soil fertility and changes to
Regional economies now in dry areas
tillage exposes soil to loss from
wind-based erosion and wet areas are at
particular risk of erosion from washout
due to extreme precipitation and here in
the Northeast
we're at high risk of this extreme
precipitation
compared to all of the regions in the
U.S we are the region that has seen the
fastest increase in extreme rain events
and looking forward to the end of the
century regardless of whether or not we
have a low or high carbon emission
scenario we will continue to be one of
the regions in the U.S that sees these
extreme rain events
okay so what does this mean right the
Farms of the future need to be resilient
to climate change and they need to
minimize environmental damage
this was the context in which I did my
PhD
okay and to address this challenge I
sought to ask can we use ecological
practices to redesign agricultural
systems and my hope is that through an
understanding of internal ecological
processes on Farmland we can help make
Farmers less uh reliant on external
inputs things like tillage or herbicides
okay so I sought to ask answer this
question in four field-based experiments
the first looks at organic no-till it's
trying to optimize the productivity and
weed suppression of no-till soybeans
the second system works with a
relatively new perennial grain called
kernsa and again it's trying to optimize
this system now chapters three and four
are slightly different in that instead
of trying to optimize an alternative
crop management system they're focused
on how we can use agricultural processes
to shape weed communities so chapter
three is looking at how weed communities
uh how their traits can respond to
ecological practices and chapter four is
looking at how specifically covered
crops can modify the phylogenetic
distance within weed communities okay
these are all different field
experiments they're all unique but
they're all tied together by this common
question which is can we use
agricultural practices to redesign
agriculture so let's see in organic
no-till systems so I accomplish organic
no-till by using a cereal Rye covered
prop
rolling it down to create a mulch and
then directly no-till planting soybeans
and there's two ecological processes
that I'm interested in here the first is
nitrogen tie up from the decomposition
of the cereal Rye Mulch and this occurs
because cereal Rye is a plant that has a
really high carbon to nitrogen ratio
like its stems are literally papery okay
so as these mulches are being decomposed
the microbes that are consuming them
need to supplement their carbon-rich
diets with nitrogen from the soil and
this creates relatively low nitrogen
availability in soils and this can be
problematic for weeds which require
nutrients to grow quickly and
aggressively
but it might not be as problematic for a
legume cash crop like soybeans right
legumes have this mutualistic
relationship with bacteria that allow
them to fix nitrogen from the air okay
and so theoretically they should be less
dependent on soil nitrogen availability
than many weeds okay now the second
ecological process that I was interested
in was the fact that soybeans are a
plant which has a relatively high
tolerance to being planted at really
high rates why does this matter well we
know that high cropping densities tend
to be more competitive to weeds because
they'll compete better for light and
space right they're really thick stands
and so in a system where you're not
using herbicides or tillage optimizing
this competition can be important and so
my idea here is that we can leverage
cereal Rye mulching and really high
seeding rates to have optimal organic
no-till systems now I tested this
question in an experiment where I had
this uniform rate of cereal Rye rolled
into a mulch and then I first no-till
planted five rates of soybeans I had a
gradient of no soybean control all the
way up to 741
000 seeds per hectare so I've got this
tremendous range from crop density
okay into each of these treatments
I applied three rates of nitrogen
fertility I had a no nitrogen control
that was really trying to look at the
effects of uh low nitrogen environment
the cereal Rye mulch and then I had a
basically intermediate and very high
nitrogen treatment okay
like all of the experiments that I'm
going to discuss today
my experimental designs use uh basically
randomized complete block design in this
case I replicated all of my experiments
and or all of my treatments in four
blocks and then did my entire experiment
at two sites so I had a total of 120
plots to work with and in each of these
plots I sampled soybean density weed
biomass and crop yields from these
yields I got at profit so let's get into
the first results which is how did my
treatments affect weed suppression
well you'll notice that all of these
lines are falling from left to right and
the x-axis is um soybean density so we
know that increasing crop densities is a
tool of weed suppression and organic
no-till you'll also notice that there's
three lines here these are my three
nitrogen treatments and as expected the
no nitrogen control had the least amount
of weed biomass so again this shows that
using low nitrogen environments and high
crop seeding rates can be used as
effective tools of weed suppression in
organic no-till now let's look at yields
okay notice that there's only one line
here what that indicates is that there
is no statistically significant effect
of fertilizing with nitrogen on soybean
yields okay and so as predicted
my soybean cash crops were able to
tolerate relatively low nitrogen
environments and that's important
because it shows that at least in this
study there is no trade-off between Weed
suppression from a low nitrogen
environment and crop yields okay at
least with soybeans
you'll notice that my yields plateaued
this was at 48 bushels per acre which
was to the T the New York State average
during the year we did this experiment
okay so organic no-till systems can be
productive
what did this mean for profits well the
the plateau and yields meant that
profits had a hyperbolic shape and they
were optimized around 527
000 seeds per hectare and that's a
relatively High rate and so this work
you know one it provides a guideline for
Farmers of how to you know have proper
seeding grates and it justifies the use
of cereal Rye mulches for weed
suppression so it applies some important
applied findings for Farmers but also to
me
it was a really important proof of
concept that thinking and applying
ecological principles to agricultural
systems can be both productive and
profitable okay and so let me remind you
of the scenarios in which this occurred
remember we had the least amount of weed
biomass when we both up
there we go when we both combined a high
soybean seeding rate as well as a low
nitrogen environment
all right and that actually underscores
one of the core principles of using
ecology to redesign agricultural systems
and this is called the many little
hammers approach for ecological weed
management
the idea here is that if you're going to
have an effective system without using a
really strong practice like herbicides
or tillage you as a farmer or researcher
should really think about combining many
tactics of weed management which might
be weakly effective in isolation but
together can create a system that is
overall effective and that's exactly
what we saw in my first chapter okay
another important principle of this
approach is that by using many practices
of weed management we can spread the
burden of control okay and so if any one
tactic fails hopefully there'll be other
approaches to weed management which end
up being successful and this is
important because it addresses the skull
of making Farm systems which are more
resilient
finally the third principle of the many
little hammers approach is that by using
diverse tactics of weed management you
create scenarios where you could have
Synergy and this is the performance of
many tactics together is better than
expected by the performance of each
single tactic on its own and so I sought
to use the many little hammers approach
to design effective first-year currency
systems now what's currenza well kernsa
is the first available uh perennial
grain to Consumers
and this is really exciting because it
lets us Envision a future where the
bread that we eat and the beer that we
drink doesn't have to come from crops
which are replaced every single year
okay another important uh component of
kernsa is that while its seed heads can
be fed to humans its stems have enough
nutrient value to be sold on forage or
livestock feed markets okay so again
this adds resilience to a farm system
now despite all of these benefits
currenza tends to grow pretty slow
during its first establishment year and
this makes it particularly vulnerable to
weed competition so thinking about the
many little hammers approach to weed
management I wanted to see whether I
could design effective first-year or
establishment near currenza systems
through the combination of multiple
ecological practices and I basically
designed an experiment that had eight
treatments okay I had an untreated
control which is you plant Kerns and the
fall it overwinters it emerges in Spring
nothing happens
I had three single tactic treatments
which were mechanical treatment that
included rotary hoeing and tine weeding
uh red clover inner crop and a spring
mowing treatment now both the tine
weeding and rotary hoeing as well as the
mowing treatment seek to knock back
weeds okay and this is important because
it'll exploit size asymmetries between
the kernsa and the smaller weeds which
emerged later in the season
uh the red clover is an inner crop so
it's basically a mat that is established
and stays throughout the season so it
should smother weeds throughout the
kearns's first year of growth and then
to test the multi uh uh multi-practice
approach I had combinations of each of
my treatments so I had a mechanical
treatment and red clover mechanical
treatment and mowing red clover and
Mowing and then a three-way combination
of treatments and so I replicated this
experiment at Mount Pleasant which is
like three miles down the road from us
and then the farm Hub which is a site in
the Hudson Valley and you'll notice that
all of my results are split across sites
because of this consistent site level
effect that you're going to see and so
the first question is could we use
ecological practices for weed
suppression in current Zen so compare
the control to the three single tactic
treatments and you'll notice that
there's always going to be at least one
letter of above These Bars that is
shared with the control so that means
statistically none of my single tactic
treatments worked at suppressing weeds
and establishment year Kearns of systems
now remember the many little hammers
approach says that when you combine
treatments there might be instances
where they function synergistically
but when we look at the multi-tastic
treatments again you'll notice that
there is no instance where weeds were
statistically lower than the control in
fact there is actually a treatment that
had higher weeds than the untreated
control so not only are my hypotheses
not supported regarding my thinking
about the many little hammers approach
but also there's some like seemingly
nonsensical results where you wouldn't
expect an untreated control to have more
weeds than a treatment which receives
you know red clover inner crops and
Mowing and so why did this happen right
um
I think we can contextualize this result
by thinking about the density of fertile
seed fertile Kerns of seed heads uh
you'll notice that at Mount Pleasant
there's no statistical differences uh
between treatments and that's that's
good that means that none of my
treatments were damaging my crop stands
but at farmhub there was a consistent
reduction in the number of fertile
currents of seed heads and what that
indicates is that my weed management
treatments despite my my best intent
were damaging karenza stands okay and
this these damage stands would create a
greater foothold for weeds to grow
relative to an untreated control so this
is why we might see a seemingly
nonsensical result now considering that
none of my treatments effectively
suppressed weeds and some of them
actually damaged Curran's stands it
shouldn't be a surprise that there was
like no case where yields were improved
by any of my treatments in this
experiment okay so like what does this
mean right right can we use uh
combinations of weed management tactics
for first-year currenza
uh no not in this study at least right
when we look at the literature you'll
find that there's quite a bit of
variability
for instance Eugene law who's an alumni
of this department uh the Ryan Lamb and
I think he might be on Zoom as well
uh did a really similar experiment to me
where he had an establishment near
kernsa and he intercropped red clover
but unlike my study he found that that
red clover suppressed weeds so what does
this mean well as a grad student and
just generally as someone who's
interested in agroecology it shows me
that ecological weed management
practices can be quite site-specific
right it's not like red clover is
inherently a failure for red for Kern's
establishment it's just it might work
better in certain sites for instance
Eugene's study was done in sites that
had only 32 percent of the weed biomass
across treatments in my study so maybe
something like red clover inner cropping
maybe it's better suited for scenarios
where you're not trying to establish
currenza in a field that's overrun by
weeds which is what I was kind of trying
to do
um you know and and just broadly
speaking I think that as a agroecologist
it's really important to either
understand
this site level variability or to design
experiments that are explicitly trying
to overcome any type of site level bias
and that's exactly what I did when I was
thinking about weed communities for my
third and fourth chapter okay and so
to make this make sense I just want to
go through a theoretical example with
you of what a traditional weed Community
analysis looks like so you know we're
all into science here let's imagine that
we're doing an experiment with
treatments a through e okay and you
might sample weeds here and you'll
notice huh there's some differences in
species across my treatments and you
might also notice that the relative
abundance of these species again it
differs across treatments so as a
researcher naturally would say is there
a treatment effect on weed community
structure
traditionally you would use a species
level approach and there's plenty of
these this is an example of an
ordination and uh just like our example
surprise surprise there was treatments a
through e okay and um
and this researcher found that their
treatments were having an effect on weed
community structure and that treatment a
was most strongly Associated to Mouse
your chickweed whereas treatment e was
strongly Associated to the increase in
the relative biomass of dandelion that's
what tear off stands for
now this is cool right this is there's
inherent value in being able to say
something like my treatments affect weed
community structure that's a powerful
result
but if you were a researcher or a farmer
who's interested in the study and you
wanted to apply it in a site that
doesn't have dandelion
right you lose this predictive ability
as to how something like whatever the
hypothetical treatment e would affect
your weed community structure okay and
so I attempted to overcome
site-specific bias or or site
specificity through a trait based
approach
the way this works is that you do start
by sampling weed species and their
relative biomass but instead of just
stopping there you'll quantify a trait
or set of traits in the weed community
okay so imagine we're looking at life
cycle whether or not weeds are annual or
perennial
then you'll look at the relative
proportion of these traits across
treatments and instead of saying
something like treatment e was
Associated to dandelion you can say
something like there's something about
treatment e that creates conditions
which will promote the dominance of
perennial weeds right that's the blue
lines there are some things about
treatment B and C that might increase
the proportion of annual weeds and so in
this way you're creating results that
are a little bit less specific to your
site or your experimental location
all right
now remember the key goal of my PhD was
to use ecological thinking to redesign
agricultural systems and conveniently
trait-based data is associated to a rich
history of ecological Theory and a
really conventional or common example of
this is community assembly Theory the
idea here is that environmental
conditions can function as filters to
whatever plant Community You observe and
these filters function on traits okay so
working with trait level data lets me
think within a community assembly
framework and I think this framework is
really applicable to agricultural
systems because agriculture is many
things but at its core it's essentially
changing environmental conditions right
and these environmental conditions or
practices can be thought of as filters
to plant communities
all right think about something like
herbicides if you were a farmer you went
out to your field and applied a broad
spectrum herbicide you would be
filtering out or killing all species
that don't have a resistance trait okay
right at the same time we also know that
things like tillage filter weed
communities and there's some more
discussion about whether or not
things like maybe selecting for a more
competitive crop cultivar also filter
weed communities but the important thing
is that we know that agricultural
practices represent filters
okay
so if I wanted to see how ecological
practices can shape weed communities a
much more succinct question that doesn't
suffer from site level bias would be how
do ecological practices affect lead
Community traits right and I answered
this question or researched it in an
organic no-till system
there's some similarities from chapter
one in that one of my experimental
variables is modifying crop density and
remember from my first chapter we know
that modifying crop density is an
effective mechanism of wheat suppression
the question here is that when we have a
more competitive context are you also
changing the traits within the weed
communities that survive this
competition and coexist
the second experimental variable was
modifying the thickness or biomass of
cereal Rye mulches
all right and and the idea here is that
regardless of the species of cover crop
mulch that you use mulches represent a
physical barrier to weed Community
emergence or to broadly weed emergence
and so when you use thicker mulches the
question is do thick mulches change the
traits within a weed community
now I did my classic approach where I
sampled my experimental variables
soybean density and mulch biomass and I
also sampled weeds at the species level
but unlike a traditional approach I then
Quantified the life cycle emergence
timing seed weight height and specific
Leaf area of every unique species that I
sampled and I worked with this trait
level data you'll notice that each of
these traits has a specific hypothesis
as to why it could be filtered by
increasing crop density or mulch biomass
now for the sake of time I just want to
focus on the life cycle of weeds and the
seed weight of the species that I was
observing across my treatments I chose
to look at these two traits because I
was mainly thinking that they would be a
filtered by modifying serial Rye mulch
biomass and the idea here is that by
having thicker barriers you're selecting
for species that have more emergence
resources so thinking about life cycles
I think that the use of a thick cover
crop mulch should be more suppressive to
annual weeds right because many
perennials can emerge through vegetative
structures that have a relatively high
amount of stored energy compared to
annuals which emerge from seed now
really focusing in on annual weeds I was
looking at seed weight okay and and the
idea here is that thick cover crop
mulches will tend to filter out small
seeded species because we know that seed
weight is associated to a plant's
ability to emerge through
thick mulches or barriers all right
so just to provide some context I'm
gonna I'm gonna start by looking at uh
the change in total weed biomass and
annual weeds okay the the x-axis here is
the increase in mulch biomass and then
the different colored lines are my five
soybean seeding rates the Bluer lines
are the higher soybean seeding rates the
denser crop stands
you'll notice that we have the most
amount of weed suppression as well as
suppression of annual weeds in these
scenarios where we use both High mulch
density and high soybean density okay
and this supports the many little
hammers approach right we also found an
interaction indicating that there might
even be some synergistic
effects of combining treatments
now my main focus of looking at life
cycle annual or perennial was thinking
about how perennial weeds would be able
to survive really thick mulches and
effectively I found that there was no
statistically significant effect of
using really thick cover crop mulches on
the suppression of perennial weeds and
in this case soybean density is on the
x-axis and what this graph shows us is a
really unexpected result which was that
the amount of perennial weeds was
affected by crop density okay and this
was both exciting and unexpected and it
shows that you can use crop competition
as a mechanism of suppressing perennial
weeds and that's a pretty important
result because perennials can oftentimes
be the bane of an organic and especially
an organic no-till farmer's existence
all right so my second trait was seed
weight
and I looked at seed weight through a
slightly different lens in that I was
looking at the community weighted mean
of seed weight and Community weighted
means are essentially weighted averages
in my study I waited my averages by the
relative abundant abundance of certain
species in my field and looking at
changes in community weighted means
essentially indicate that a
environmental filter is pushing a trait
towards a certain functional composition
and so when we look at the change in
community-weighted mean of seed weight
you'll notice that it increases across
my mulch biomass gradient okay and that
supports this hypothesis that thick
physical barriers will filter out
lighter seeded species
so what does this all mean right
well I think there's two important
takeaways from the study
the four the first is kind of this proof
of concept which is that again
ecological thinking can be used not only
to suppress weeds but also to shape weed
communities why does this matter well
this matters because if a farmer was to
come up to me and say
I've got this perennial wheat how do I
best manage it you know with this
research I could tell them you know
maybe you're not going to be as
successful investing in a really thick
cover crop mulch as you would be
thinking about using the most
competitive crop you could okay and so
you know it's not like you're going to
get complete suppression of your
perennial weeds but
there's more probability that you're
going to have success in the system
the second important I think finding of
this study is that it develops our ideas
of the many little hammers approach
because it shows that not only is the
combination of ecological weed
management practices better at just
suppressing weeds but also that diverse
weed managing practices can filter
different weed functional traits and
this matters because the use of many
ecological weed management practices
could be more effective at having a more
holistic weed suppression and creating
systems where you won't end up with one
really problematic dominant wheat okay
mulch is suppressed small seeded annuals
whereas crop competition was more
effective at suppressing things like
perennials
now another way to look at weed
communities while overcoming site level
bias is to think about the phylogenetic
distance within weed communities
the way this works is that you first
start by mapping out the evolutionary
relationship between species
and then you look at phylogenetic
distance and compare the phylogenetic
distance of different treatments now you
might say but URI like I'm still seeing
species names in your comparison of
treatments how is this not a species
level approach which is you know going
to be Associated to site level variables
and
you know I I would just remind you to
think about what a phylogenetic tree
means
right phylogenies show evolutionary
relationships and we know that the
position of plant species across a
phylogenetic tree will reflect its
overall functional identity right there
is going to be always convergent
evolution across plant phylogenies but
overall it phylogenies reflect
functional uh uh grouping
now why does this matter I mean imagine
that you're working with uh two thistles
right a a
dandelion and a Canada thistle these two
weeds will be more phylogenetically
similar and also more functionally
similar than the dandelion and a giant
foxtail for instance and so at the
community level when you see a community
that has more phylogenetic distance
that's an indication that that Community
is also more functionally diverse okay
if you see a community that's less
phylogenetic less phylogenetically
distance you know that there's perhaps
some filtering towards a particular
functional identity
and thinking about what we know
regarding phylogeny and ecological
Theory we know that the phylogenetic
grouping of plants is associated to
their Fitness in different environments
and there's plenty of experiments that
show this uh this example is from
Jonathan Silvertown where he did an
experiment modifying water logging
conditions and found that a plant's
phylogenetic grouping was Associated to
its success in these different
environments and I mean that makes sense
like think about whether or not you were
to plant a cactus in a marsh right any
plant from the cactus family would do a
lot worse in that Marsh than the plant
from the lily family right success in
different environments is
overall Associated to phylogenetic
grouping so thinking about this
ecological Theory
I wanted to see whether or not the use
of cover crops created environments that
affected the phylogenetic distance of
weed communities so my assumption here
is that cover crops are modifying
environments okay and I don't think this
assumption is too far off right just
think about a field of sorghum sedan
grass cover crop and a sun sun hemp
cover crop these two species are really
densely planted they'll create soil
environments at the soil surface that
are shaded but there's also some species
level specificity their effects on the
environment I mean let's just think
about my legume non-legum example that
I've been running with for this
presentation
the Sorghum sedan grass is a non-legium
cover crop that means it needs to use up
soil uh nitrogen from the soil okay so
as it grows it should create
environments that have relatively less
nitrogen than something like a legume
crap cover crop
like sun hemp right that sun hemp can
fix some of its own nitrogen from the
atmosphere so the environments under
these two cash crops should be
relatively different
and I would think that a weed that's
related to sorghum sedan grass and might
also not be able to fix its own nitrogen
should do worst under these environments
and so my hypothesis
is that cover crops create conditions
that most intensely suppress
phylogenetically related weed species
now to test this hypothesis I did a
study at two sites in New York state
Musgrave which is down the road from us
and the Hudson Valley Farm Hub and the
study was composed of two experiments
okay a winter cover crop experiment and
a summer cover crop experiment and one
thing I want you to remember is that
winter cover crops are planted in the
fall they're present in the winter and
they've already had time to modify
habitat conditions when summer annual
weeds are emerging whereas some recover
crops are planted in the spring at the
same time as the emergence of a lot of
Summer annual weeds okay the way these
experiments were designed was that there
was one tilt control
and four cover crop treatments uh in the
winter cover crop experiment this was
canola Harry vetch cereal rye and a
cereal Rye hairy veg mix in the summer
cover crop experiment I had that tilled
control then the buckwheat the sun hemp
sorghum sedan grass which is the picture
you saw and then a mix of the Sorghum
sedan grass Sun hemp mix
because this is a randomized complete
block design all of these treatments are
replicated and this yielded a total of
120 different plots and each of these
plots I sampled weed communities okay so
now I've got 120 data frames of species
and their relative biomass
I then used right now the largest known
molecular-based phylogenetic tree of
vascular plants to create 120 unique
phylogenes okay one for each of these
communities
I then calculated the phylogenetic
spread of each of these trees using a
metric called interspecific mean
pairwise distance this is a really
special metric because
to my knowledge at least right now in
2023 it's the only metric that can be
weighted by biomass so it takes into
account the relative proportion of weeds
in the field as well as is independent
of the relative richness of my different
samples so if I was to sample a weed
Community with five leads or 30 weeds I
should get some type of accountability
for the fact that a community with 30
unique species is more likely to be
phylogenetically spread
once I had this data I could answer the
question whether or not cover crops
affect wheat communities so first I
looked at whether or not cover crops
suppressed my weeds just to provide
context then I wanted to see whether or
not the overall phylogenetic distance in
cover crop treatments was different than
that under a control and finally whether
or not the phylogenetic similarity
between a cover crop and a weed affected
its interactions okay that's like the
final boss
um so first question right to provide
some context do cover crops suppress
weeds well you're going to see a graph
that has my two sites and the winter
cover crop experiment and the summer
cover crop experiment and I want you to
compare the tilled controls to the the
cover crop plot so the open circles and
so to cover crops suppress weeds
unequivocally yes right all of my cover
crop treatments reduced weed biomass on
average by 58 but there were four cover
crop treatments that had up to 99 weed
suppression okay so if anyone is like
cover cropping it's like a nice idea but
it won't always work
you know it can it can work really well
but we already kind of knew that from
past experiments right really
interesting stuff comes when we look at
the phylogenetic spread of cover crops
relative to the tilled controls and so
what you're seeing here is inner
specific mean pairwise distance this is
a unitless number the larger the values
the more spread there is
phylogenetically within a community so
in the winter cover crops we know that
the Tilt control in the canola had the
same amount of phylogenetic spread but
my other three cover crop treatments the
cereal Rye hairy vetch and Cyril Rye
hairy veg mix add less phylogenetic
spread there's less
perhaps functional diversity within a
phylogenic perspective in these plots
right they kind of you know you can
imagine their trees to be less spread
than the Tilt control in the canola
now in the summer cover crops none of my
treatments were different the Tilt
controls and this was so interesting
because remember all of my cover crop
treatments suppressed weeds all of them
both in the winter and summer cover crop
experiment but only the cover crops that
overwintered
or had some more time to modify habitat
conditions before the emergence of
Summer annual weeds had the possibility
of modifying phylogenetic distance okay
and so
you know I'm not directly modifying the
the relative emergence of cover crops
compared to weeds but I have again some
indication or tie back to the
fundamental theory of phylogenetic
distance and plant Fitness which is you
need to have a modification in
environments
now final question okay of this whole
presentation
this phylogenetic relatedness impact the
the interactions between cover crops and
weeds okay the way I calculated this was
by looking at the change in phylogenetic
distance of a plant community that only
included weeds and then that same plant
Community including its cover crop so if
there's a value above zero I know that
the cover crop is phylogenetically
distinct from the weeds it coexisted
with okay and when we look at my results
you'll see that there's you know all of
the treatments observationally are at or
above zero there's no instance where
weeds were more clustered around the
cover crop than expected by random
chance and when we focus in on the three
cover crops that had indications of
filtering weed Community phylogenies we
can see that they're all either
significant or marginally significantly
distinct phylogenetically from the weeds
that coexisted with them so what does
this mean well this means that when
cover crops filter weed communities they
tend to be most suppressive to
phylogenetically related species and
that that aligns with my thinking of
that original sorghum sedan grass and
the non-legging wheat
okay and so
thinking back to my first phylogenetic
result
we think that this is more possible when
the cover crops are also established
prior to the emergence of weeds and so
what does this study mean well it
provides some preliminary indication
that you know if someone was to say Udi
I want to manage this one problematic
weed with cover crops what's my best bet
I could tell them well you know one
select a competitive cover crop but two
try to select the species that's
phylogenetically related to it and if
you can try to manage it in a way where
it's established prior to the emergence
of your problematic need right that's
it's creating these more effective
Management Systems
all right I'm really I mean that's kind
of this like overall view of my of my
PhD and so after like uh
like four years worth of experiments
right
I come back to my original question
which is can we use ecological practices
to redesign agriculture
I think we can
I mean in chapter one
I showed that we can redesign organic
no-till systems to be productive and
profitable using ecological processes in
chapters three and four I showed that we
can hopefully change the shape or
structure of weed communities using
ecological thought
you know but but I wasn't always
successful right I had this study
chapter two where you know nothing
seemed to work
um and you know I think this just shows
that ecological weed management or
ecological practices on the whole
they're really knowledge intensive right
there's no such thing as a silver bullet
in agriculture
I mean just think back to like how I
started this talk right
I started thinking about you know kovid
showed us that food systems are
vulnerable the global Supply chains can
be easily broken and that workers in the
food system aren't treated equitably and
I don't pretend that ecological crop and
weed management will go close to
resolving any of these problems
but I do think that hopefully it can
make farm systems a little bit more
resilient to climate change and it can
make them you know maybe a little bit
less damaging to the environment and so
I think I hope that
if my PhD or if my work here as a grad
student at Cornell means anything to
anyone it's that I hope that we can
acknowledge that we can always use our
research to hopefully redesign
agricultural systems right we should
never compromise for systems that damage
the environment or are socially unjust
so with that uh thanks again for being
here a huge thanks to my committee for
supporting me academically and
intellectually throughout the process
Brian lab you guys are friends and
collaborators for life
my other collaborators you know I I feel
honored to work with funding thank you
so much made everything possible and
then finally a huge thank you to my
family and friends so thanks
if you have time for a couple questions
today
I saw your hand first Yes actually let
me turn on the speakers in the room
okay hopefully people on Zoom can hear
you uh
yeah
yeah so hopefully people on Zoom comment
if you couldn't hear the question and
I'll repeat it but I'll just they
couldn't hear it they could or could not
hear it okay so for people on Zoom
correct me if I was wrong at
interpreting it I found that the mulch
biomass of cover crops in chapter 3 was
Associated to more weed suppression but
does that actually improve yields
right that's a great question
um so you know what do we know about
cover crops well there's some like
really interesting meta-analyzes on
cover crops that show that
their effect on yields can be quite
variable like on average in the Corn
Belt for corn and soybean they'll have
marginal reductions and crop yields but
that's typically in conventional systems
remember that I'm trying to work in
systems that don't use herbicides or use
less herbicides than tillage and so my
thinking is that in these systems the
weed suppression that you'll get from a
cover crop should reduce the overall
seed banks and across time as you rotate
to different crops uh you'll hopefully
have systems that are less constrained
by weeds and they should be more
productive uh because they'll be they'll
have less weeds to compete with so
um
I think the answer is that within a
context that's trying to reduce tillage
and herbicides the effects of a covered
crop Mulch on the whole will have in the
long term beneficial effects on yields
hopefully
Harold I saw your hand
s yeah
I'm sorry I guess
in your first chapter did you see a
pretty consistent
um like spatial distribution of weed
biomass or do you think that is
to get up to the higher seeding rate and
keep the economic benefits with like a
more targeted seating rate
oh yeah that's a great question okay so
for Zoom uh you know I I had this study
my first chapter which was looking at
soybean seeding rates and the question
is
um can I have a more targeted approach
to high seeding rates where instead of
having an entire field seated at 520 uh
thousand soybean seeds per hectare I
could have targeted seeding I think
that's totally possible that is so
interesting I mean weeds definitely do
grow in in patches especially like
perennials that that emerge vegetatively
and uh that creep so theoretically yeah
totally and that would make a lot more
economic sense
um I would love to do that work yeah
great question thanks for the idea
uh more questions
yes in the back
um
yeah so resume the questions were about
chapter two and four
okay
yeah yeah so so how do like if I was to
one did I replicate my experiment across
multiple years and two like thinking
about climate variability across sites
how would that affect my results that's
that's a question for people on Zoom
um so uh I replicated the phylogenetic
experiment chapter four and the trait
based experiment chapter three across
both space and time
chapters one and two were only done
replicated across space but they were
done in the same year
um so generally speaking what does that
mean well that means that when I don't
replicate across time there's inherently
more of that site level specificity
right because uh we know that things
like no-till planting soybeans into a
silver Rye mulch tend to work a lot
better during wet year years okay
um because that's real right mulch is
consuming soil moisture uh 2019 which is
when I did my soybean optimization study
was I think a relatively wet year if I
remember correctly
um at least it wasn't like last summer
uh but I think that
inherently the more replication you have
for these
experiments that are working with
ecological practices the more you can
try to account for and minimize site
level variability okay I I yeah I think
that that's there's
like I said it's really important to try
to acknowledge that site level
variability uh and the more replication
you have
the easier it is to you know not be
constrained by it
so yeah
cool
um
anyone else your your opportunity to to
make me cry
no questions on Zoom
okay well I won't cry all right thanks
I
you have a question about phylogenies I
am here
hi Peter Woodbury here can you hear me
I can hear you loud and clear
great uh thanks for your great work
um
I had a question of for your phylogeny
analysis whether you whether you have or
whether you might
if you haven't whether you might want to
analyze those data by trait sort of as
as you're in your previous analysis yeah
and then kind of use phylogeny to mop up
any residual to see if phylogeny has any
predictive power after you already
account for traits that you expect to be
important
yeah I definitely
um so I don't have trait level data
that's can you hear me by the way
because I know there's a lot of
background noise
yes loud and clear great so
um I I have not associated trait level
data to those weed communities uh I
chose not to because
well first of all I think it would be
really valuable to do that but in this
case for that isolated study I chose not
to because I think it's really important
to have a specific hypothesis as to why
and how your ecological suppression
mechanisms can affect or filter traits
and that's really easy when you have
something like modifying the thickness
of a cereal Rye mulch selecting for more
emergence resources or modifying crop
density of soybeans to shade out weeds
but it becomes a lot harder at least for
me to hypothesize how using different
species of cover crops how how
specifically that'll affect the traits
within the community that's not saying
that I have like no thinking of what
traits would be affected but I think
that by using phylogenies I took a much
more broad approach and that's why I
avoided looking at traits because I I
didn't know which ones out of the
infinite range of traits to study if
that makes sense uh that was my
reasoning but I do think it's there it's
really valuable to combine trait level
and phylogenetic approaches
are you still there can you do uh good
yes uh thanks for that again just you
know I was suggesting combining the two
so pick some traits you think are
important and test how much explanation
you get from those and then the
remainder
can be uh you can use phylogeny to see
what remaining explanation can be gained
yeah yeah no I definitely think that
those studies are really valuable
um
I really do I I think that is a good
suggestion for sure thanks
okay well if everyone
think there's no one else on uh Zoom so
I will
turn off the mic and um
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu